I'd rather be with in bat mite than
you who's badmind the two-foot-tall
interdimensional imp who stans batman i'd
rather be with him that's real good yeah
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
full dc peacemaker episode 1 through episode
3 video they just released the first three
episodes so there's a whole bunch of easter
eggs and justice league connections it is part
of the dceu so i'll explain what's going on
if you're brand new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the episodes i will
do videos for all the episodes just depending on
how everybody feels about the series careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the first couple of
episodes yet we'll just start at the beginning and
work our way through shot by shot talking about
the big easter eggs justice league connections and
big name drops as we go through the episodes super
villain that's a misconception i'm a superhero
batman is a superhero i'll start with episode
one then i'll do episode two then i'll do episode
three at the end of the video but they're doing
the same naming convention that they do for the
mandalorian series the star wars book of boba fett
episodes so it's episode 1 chapter 1 a whole new
world and the world is a reference to him whirling
around at the end of the episode with that woman
who winds up being the butterfly but if it wasn't
clear this series is taking place inside the dceu
in present day about five months or so after the
events of the suicide squad movie that post-credit
scene where peacemaker is shown alive in the
hospital recovering there are several mentions
of different justice league characters throughout
the series like they do a lot of batman superman
even aquaman references in this first episode i'll
point those out too but a lot of the early part of
the first episode is meant to reintroduce you to
the peacemaker character and kind of remind you
who he is where he comes from and what's going
on james gunn did say the peacemaker series is
supposed to set up a future big dc project like
crossover the same way the marvel disney plus
series do with the big marvel movies but for the
peacemaker episodes james gunn filmed all them
himself like he was the director of the writer
for all the episodes and he said that there are
post-credits scenes for every episode so if you
saw the post credits scenes for the first three
episodes it's going to be like that for every
single episode the actual opening scene starts
with him waking up in the hospital where we saw
him in that post-credits scene the mount rouge
hospital in evergreen the town where he lives
and where most of this series is taking place
if you're not a big comic book reader evergreen
is from the green lantern comics within the dc
eu here it's located in charlton county and
that's a reference to the charlton comics
where peacemaker originally came from but the idea
that this is taking place in a green lantern city
in the butterflies or part of this larger alien
invasion setup i think that the series is going
to slowly tease the big green lantern hbo series
that we're going to be watching next year the door
to the lair of that senator who's the butterfly is
glowing green kind of like green lantern there are
veins of green running through the rocks in his
underground layer but you guys can let me know in
the comments what other big upcoming dc project
do you think they're going to use this to tease
they discharge him and introduced rizwan mongi's
jameel character who's one of the janitors there's
a bunch of jokes with his character but he is
meant to be a larger character in the later
episodes you kind of get the vibe from his
character pretty much everybody on the show
all these main characters are meant to be kind of
shady like even his janitor character is kind of
shady because he says he's not trustworthy and he
went to mit but he's working as a janitor because
he just doesn't want the responsibility they make
their first big justice league reference when he
starts making fun of peacemaker for being so dumb
like you're not a hero aquaman's a hero and they
make this big joke about aquaman doing it with
fish james gunn said the peacemaker is kind of new
to the internet so to speak like he just doesn't
know how the internet works so he believes that
everything he reads on the internet is completely
true all over social media they even make a pepe
the frog meme reference when he says the person
who told him about aquaman having sex with fish
was named pepe the frog there's a bunch of
references to the suicide squad movie like he has
a postcard from cortal mates that he apparently
picked up while they were on their mission there
he still has corto maltese currency which he tries
to use to pay for his cab ride the mr murn that
the nurse text is the team leader for their black
ops team inside argus or task force x they're like
a side quest group inside amanda waller's larger
argus organization he's not from the comics there
are a couple of the characters on the team here
that they created for the show but a lot of the
other big characters in the series are comic book
characters in this whole weird funny intro they
have with the 80s song is just meant to be like
a fantasy that he's having like you're meant to
watch this series as if you're seeing inside
peacemaker's head the way he thinks of himself
they also use this intro to literally introduce
you to the other major characters like this is
dceu vigilante this is leota we find out that
she's actually secretly amanda waller's daughter
she's meant to be like the rookie on the team
because as she says she was trained in military
ops and amanda waller has been trying to bring her
into argus but she's kind of been resisting that
like in episode three she gets kind of gun-shy and
can't kill that guard this guy like i said is murn
he's the team leader james gunn also just cast him
as a secret character in guardians of the galaxy 3
it's rumored that he's going to be the mcu
high evolutionary but i guess we'll find out
when they release the first trailer for that you
all remember emilia harcourt from the suicide
squad movie john economos this is a new character
kia she's playing leota's wife and you all know
robert patrick he's playing peacemaker's father
they actually reveal later that he is dceu white
dragon he's basically like this white supremacist
super villain from the comics but that answers a
lot of questions about why he has that secret
lair with the portal in all those weapons just
like miles and miles of weapons in some secret
location this is sophie song and her partner
larry fitzgibbon they're detectives who just keep
running into peacemaker and the task force x team
because of all the collateral damage that they
cause there's also a special easter egg for the
fitzgibbon character too he's not from dc comics
but james gunn has always had a character in all
of his movies called larry fitzgibbon so it's more
of a james gun easter egg not so much a dc easter
egg behind them is just one of the other local
police officers played by christopher herredol
who you might recognize from all the stargate
tv shows this is yamil's janitor character who
you just met he becomes a bigger character later
in the series this old man here is his father's
neighbor he drops a whole bunch of justice league
references and batman references and right at the
end judo master jumps out he's kind of like a
mid-level villain we'll see what they wind up
doing with him in the later episodes he is a
comic book character like i said he debuted in
the original charlton comics where peacemaker came
from before dc bought charlton and they all became
dc characters and this is eagly his pet bald eagle
yes that is correct he has a pet bald eagle but he
uses him more as like a sidekick like he says best
friend sidekick like batman and robin or if you
want to make a batman animal sidekick reference
batman and duke from the comics if you didn't
watch the credits d bradley baker is playing
the voice of eagly he does all the eagle sounds
a lot of you might remember him as the voice of
momo and appa from avatar the last airbender he's
also done a ton of star wars animated characters
the symbol here on the episode title is the dub
of peace that's the symbol that he has on all of
his gear it becomes a big plot device in episode
three too like he feels like he can't kill
someone unless the devil peace is on the gun
but that's really just part of a big panic attack
that he's having then as they start introducing
you to the other characters leota makes a
bunch of james bond references to octopussy
because she was expecting the secret black ops
mission in the series to be something a little
bit sexier a little bit grander things will get
super huge and crazy later on like with each
new episode episode 1 episode 2 episode 3 things
get continually bigger and bigger and bigger she
also makes a sharknado reference and then when
the cab driver won't take peacemaker's cultural
maltese currency he has to give him the helmet
that he wore on the last suicide squad mission
but that's just to set up the twist with all the
other helmets that a father has with the special
functions and all the special weapons he keeps in
that secret base they reveal peacemaker's house
obviously going with the theme here his mobile
home painted to look like the american flag the
reason they give him this funny entrance jumping
in the side because he can't find the key is also
just to give you a quick tour of his bedroom just
to give you a vibe for his character but as you
can see most of his furniture the design all of
his records his music is all from the 80s that's
why most of the music for the series the songs
that you hear in the episodes are all either hair
metal or classic rock bands then they sort of set
up the vigilante character like he has a billion
missed calls and messages from vigilante he is
the adrian chase version of the character they
did a version of him on arrow but it was just
like a vastly different version from the comics
this version is also a little bit different from
the comics too they're just playing him super
goofy and super crazy just like peacemaker they
make a big godzilla touhou monster verse reference
when peacemaker thinks that they're fighting
mothra like oh we're fighting a giant moth because
the mission is codenamed butterfly in project
starfish starro was a giant starfish the payoff
though is that yes they are kind of fighting
space butterflies but is a small insectoid race
with advanced technology my early theory right now
because there's all this talk of alphas and this
hive structure in this honey drinking like they
drink this weird honey fluid in episode three
that they might be connected to queen bee and
hive or a version of those characters from the
dc comics queen bee is a big justice league and
green lantern villain there's a bunch of different
versions of the characters then she eventually
takes over a version of hive the one i'm talking
about is the alien version of the character
but to make a marvel reference we kind of
have a version of secret invasion going on where
you have them basically taking over human hosts
then they introduce his father played by robert
patrick in his muscle car it's a 1970s mercury
comet james gunn himself called it a really shifty
car like one of the worst muscle cars of all time
even though you don't get a good look at the
license plate you do see it on the posters here
it's meant to say peacemaker but the way it's
written it sounds kind of like piss maker which is
exactly the kind of thing the peacemaker would do
punking himself the number 986 on his house might
be a reference to the mid-80s when dc bought
charlton comics and the peacemaker character
became a dc character but his first dc series
didn't start till 1988. his neighbor makes a
big batman reference and obviously because this is
inside the dceu he's talking about ben affleck's
batman and probably the other biggest batman
easter egg that surprised me was the idea that
batmite actually exists in the dc eu who's batman
the two foot tall interdimensional imp who stands
batman i'd rather be with him does it real
good yeah if you haven't read a lot of the old
batman comics batmite is basically like a fifth
dimensional creature just like Mister Mxyzptlk
it basically does the same thing to batman that
Mister Mxyzptlk does to superman just messes with
him and john economos is very clear he's
like no no it's real it actually happened
so ben affleck's batman at some point in his
history dealt with this interdimensional creature
when they go in the house though there's
this whole fox news type show going on about
how liberals in america are secretly aliens
plotting to take down the country obviously
that's meant to foreshadow the big reveal about
project butterfly that there are actual aliens
who are masquerading as humans like scrolls
in the mcu love the way they play all these
eagly scenes here too this is mostly done with a
lot of special effects but they treat the eagle
like it really is his sidekick like it literally
hugs him dad grab my phone i don't want to move
dad when peacemaker is bonding with his
father over blood sports terrible father
in the story about how he locked him in the
crate with the starving rats for 24 hours
and his father just can't get enough of it
they're trying to show you how much of a
psychopath his father is but also because we find
out that he's this classic dc comic book villain
i think they're trying to slowly set him up as
a bigger villain during the course of the series
maybe not the main villain but i think they're
just trying to set up this larger confrontation
that peacemaker will have with his father then
they reveal the special portal disguises the door
in the garage and teleports them to this massive
weapon storage depot that his father has with all
this bleeding edge tech which they do not explain
yet i love the fact that they don't explain how
his father has all this they're just miles and
miles full of weapons here it kind of looks like
his father even has some legit nuclear warheads or
at least some giant rocket here in the center so
to make another james bond reference his father
is kind of like the psychopathic cue but like i
said he himself used to be a vigilante when his
father says the helmets were from before he went
into prison the idea is that his father had been
training to be this hardcore weapon but peacemaker
doesn't want to be evil but the funny thing here
is that even though his father is legit crazy
he does give him some solid advice like which
helmet should i pick here which special function
and he gives him the sonic helmet which does serve
him well at the end of the episode they reveal the
first person that he's supposed to kill the first
butterfly is this shady us senator who is the
person that they kill in episode three so it takes
a little while to get there but they do eventually
get there then after peacemaker strikes out with
emilia harcourt he winds up inadvertently going
home with one of the butterflies although they do
reveal the butterfly was also kind of watching him
while he was watching amelia harcourt like he was
stalking her but he himself was also kind of being
stalked on the side so when they transitioned to
the caterpillar in front of her apartment that's
meant to pay off the mothra godzilla project
butterfly joke he winds up hooking up with
one of the butterflies then the whole thing with
the amanda waller cameo scene is obviously they
just want to remind you that she's a big part of
this series even though she's not in every single
episode and revealed that she is leota's mother
in what's really going on with project butterfly
there's another batman reference on peacemaker's
diary and the reason why she calls it a forgery is
probably because they stole peacemaker's diary and
made a fake copy and they're trying to swap back
in the fake copy and just hide it in his trailer
somewhere where he won't find it my early theory
is that they probably stole his real diary and
it might have something to do with his father's
secret weapons and all the tech and his secret
past as the dceu white dragon villain like on
the side amanda waller might be investigating his
father love the giant fight scene the peacemaker
has in his tighty whities fighting the butterfly
who's also in her underwear and using the helmet
that his father suggested to him like oh it
turns out that sonic helmet worked pretty good
like as crazy as his father is it does sound
like he knows his stuff it does sound like he's
actually pretty smart but the post-credits scene
does make you question that just a little bit
the actual post-credits scene is really just for
the scabies helmet like it's a longer version of
the new helmet scene of him looking at all the
special functions in legit one of the helmets is
just designed to give him scabies not anyone else
just him they're either going to pay that off in a
future episode with another joke or is just meant
to make you think that his father could 50 50 be
crazy or a genius probably a little bit of both
the title of episode 2 chapter 2 is best friends
for never which is a reference to the vigilante
character they fully introduce the vigilante
character in his costume and they start working
on the actual butterfly missions in a bigger way
detective song makes a superman reference saying
that she hopes this isn't some capes thing she
also references vigilante implying that he's been
going around killing people in the area for a long
time the other big joke here too is how he runs
back to the apartment to steal all of his gear and
takes all that time to find his socks everything
and put it back on and steal all of her 80s music
and junk and just happens upon a piece of their
alien technology so sticky fingers did pay off and
they use this to set up the joke for the end of
the episode where the wife does wind up sleeping
with peacemaker and vigilante in a big threesome
bonding over their mutual love of hair metal bands
amelia harcourt makes a jason bourne reference
john economos is the person who's responsible
for peacemaker's father getting thrown in prison
although with a little bit of help from leota and
the couple who they bribed to lie about peacemaker
he also references harley quinn and weasel
remember the suicide squad movie post credit scene
revealed that weasel is still alive and running
around the jungles of quartal maltese unless they
went and got him later and i already explained
the bat might seem like him basically saying
there is a real version of batmite in the dceu
if you look around the office space that they move
into here to run their missions it's basically an
old video rental store and if you look around the
room like zoom in enhance on all the shelves here
on all the walls there's a whole bunch of funny
references to fake movies the whole shootout that
he has with vigilante to celebrate is just meant
to be a callback to his competition that he had
with bloodsport during the suicide squad movie to
see who could pull off the best trick shots this
one is just meant to be a little more celebratory
like he's having a little bit more fun with it
and afterwards like i said they pay off the
joke with amber wanting to screw him with the
big threesome and they pay off the reveal with
the alien tech like it's just a tiny alien ship
like the aliens themselves are really tiny and
just living inside regular humans like parasites
controlling them that's why in episode 3 pacemaker
makes the homunculus reference the episode 2 post
credit scene just winds up being a funnier
longer version of the couple looking at all
the different photos identifying peacemaker's
father as the actual person at the crime scene
the title of episode 3 is better golf dead which
is a reference to the senator that peacemaker was
originally supposed to kill and it's just
taken them this long to get to the mission
peacemaker references dceu doll man he's kind of
like a discount version of dc's atom or ant-man if
you want to think of a marvel reference doll man
only has shrinking powers though and like i said
earlier peacemaker references that he has an older
brother who will probably meet in a future episode
or in a flashback if he's dead in present day in
apparently pro tip be careful about whatsapp on
your phones if you send each other nudes maybe you
should just lay off sending each other pictures
like that anyway they said of the judo master
character he's exactly what he sounds like he's
just a regular martial arts expert he doesn't have
any special superpowers he comes from the original
old school charlton comics where peacemaker came
from so that's why they're using him on the show
shout out for berenstain bears in the mandela
effect there's a big joke about the mandela effect
because they argue is it berenstain bears was it
berenstein bears it really was berenstain bears
leota is correct like she shows them the picture
later and he's like ah that has to be photoshopped
that can't be real the children's books it's
bearing stained bears not berenstein beers
they also make a cobra kai karate kid reference
netflix just released cobra chive and they
actually just brought back terry silver from
karate kid 3 as the new big bad of the series
then the whole thing with not being able to take
out the family is just meant to be him having
this crisis of conscience crisis of faith however
you want to think about it that's the whole deal
with the dev of peace like he freaks out because
there's not a dove of peace on the gun oh i can't
shoot him if there's not a devil peace symbol on
it like i said earlier i think the reason they're
drinking the weird honey fluid is probably a
tip-off that they're connected to queen bee
and hive from the justice league in the green
lantern comics the joke about the flaming hot
cheetos is probably just a product integration
like paid placement advertisement that they
turned into a joke or maybe james gunn just
really likes his flamin hot cheetos they do
finally give john economos a win after spending
the last three episodes making fun of him non-stop
taking down judo master using the van one
and then two finishing him off with a crowbar
they do wind up taking out the senator after he
winds up cutting off about half of vigilante's
toe and shocking his balls to hell and they
reveal that there are theoretically thousands
of these butterfly alien creatures all over the
world not so much russia for some reason not
sure why they're avoiding russia so much parts of
northern africa most of australia northern canada
really what's going on here is they're just
focused around the biggest population centers
in the episode three post-credit scene is just
meant to be a longer version of the vigilante
scene where he shows up to help them revealing
that his whole family is dead like i said they'll
probably give us a big vigilante flashback in a
future episode to explain what happened to his
family but everyone post all your theories about
project butterfly in the comments which alien
group do you think the bugs belong to and who is
the real main villain but my peacemaker episode 4
video will post next week after my star wars book
of boba fett episode video so we'll see how the
peacemaker videos do if everyone is digging the
show and the video does well i will continue doing
episode videos for it every week everyone click
here for my full book of boba fett episode 3 video
and click here for my eternals deleted scene
for kit harington's black knight character
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!